harmony when you land on an alien planet
take a look at the toothy chittering
horrors that maybe want to eat you and
say damn those guys are cool
so you pursue the Harmony affinity you
get some bug buddies learn to breathe
miasma and generally make all your stuff
look greenish and lumpy so what does it
take to win and what kind of alien
megafauna can you wield against your
enemies the Harmony victory is pretty
research heavy requiring three separate
texts before you really get going
transgenics swarm intelligence and nano
robotics are kind of all over the place
on the tech web so it behooves you to
boost your science output by not only
making some science eQuest decisions but
also by sending your covert agents to
robble robble a bunch of little blue
flasks from your fellow colonizers and
during the mid game you're going to want
to lock down a bunch of Zeno mass
resources for later on or just line up a
bunch of favors with your trading
partners and call in the Zeno mass once
the time comes to build elite units once
you've got those three texts under your
belt it's time to build the mind flower
this wonder takes up a tile on your
territory and can be destroyed by bad
guys so pick one that's fairly
defensible I wasn't at war with anyone
yet but I still laid down a barrier of
miasma across the borders of my capital
and threw up a combat boosting TAC net
satellite just in case while the mind
flower is being constructed by your
capital have your other cities build
mind stem and Zeno sanctuary buildings
these will hasten the awakening of the
planet once the mind stem is complete
meanwhile send your research tendrils
out to designer life-forms and alien
evolution so you can build some badass
military units in case anyone gets
nervous about your efforts to transcend
humanity the rocktopus is a giant
floating man of war that can fly up into
the orbital lair and support the ground
units below in a bunch of ways and also
sling gooey alien death down on cities
that are encroaching on your turf it
doesn't launch like a normal orbital
unit so you have to move it to the place
you want and then float it straight up
the ultimate harmony unit however is the
Zeno Titan which is basically a giant
insectile kaiju that will romp anything
in its way just look at this beast it's
pretty much terrifying and everyone will
want to kill it so support it with some
other units and show kozlov that harmony
is the way feel the harmony friend after
10 or so turns of full-on mind flowering
voila like the light of dawn you will
enter the next phase of humanity's
evolution and finally understand your
place in the universe
sounds pretty peaceful actually